DON'T YOU HATE THAT ERROR
MESSAGE ON THE TREADMILL AND YOU
ARE LIKE, WHAT ARE YOU SUPPOSED
TO DO WITH THE NUMBER?
>> WE HAVE TO MOVE ON.
THE ART EXHIBIT IN THE
NETHERLANDS,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTED
THIS, HERE IS WHAT THEY SAID.
MODERN, I AM SAYING, MODERN ART
IS WHAT IT REPRESENTS IN THIS
CASE.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT ENORMOUS TERD
SCULPTURES.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" DESCRIBED
IT THAT WAY.
IT IS AN EXHIBITION WHERE YOU
CAN WALK THROUGH THE EXCREMENT.
WHEN BODY FUNCTIONS BECOME, WHEN
BODILY FUNCTIONS ARE THE FOCUS
OF ART, WE ARE IN TROUBLE.
HOW DO WE GET FROM THE PIETA TO
FECAL MATTER.
THESE ARE ENORMOUS --
>> Laura: WHAT IS IT SUPPOSED
TO TELL US?
THAT LIFE IS BIG TERD?
>> IT LOOKS LIKE YOUR DOG JIMMY
WALKED IN.
IT IS AN ENORMOUS DOG JUST DROP
THIS.
WHAT THIS MEANS AND WHY IT IS
HERE, I DO NOT KNOW.
BUT THEY HAVE DONE SCULPTURES IN
THE PAST IN 2005, THEY DID A
SCULPTURE OF FROZEN URINE.
THE ONLY THING I LIKE ABOUT THE
EXHIBIT, EVERYBODY HAD THE SAME
DETERMINATION.
IT IS CRAP.
>> Laura: NOW A NEW EXHIBIT,
SPEAKING OF EXHIBITS THAT IS NOT
CRAP.
AT THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN MUSEUM
IN WASHINGTON, OPRAH WINFREY HAS
A BIG EXHIBIT.
>> A TAX PAYER SHRINE TO OPRAH.
240 ARTIFACTS, SHE WALKED AROUND
WITH GAYLE KING.
IT IS CALLED WATCHING OPRAH.
>> THE "OPRAH WINFREY SHOW," AND
AMERICAN CULTURE.
I LOVE IT.
>> LOOK AT THAT.
>> OPRAH WINFREY IS THE REASON
THAT I LOVE MYSELF SO FIERCELY
AND KNOW THAT MY VOICE MATTERS.
THAT MAKES ME WANT TO CRY.
>> THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS WAS
YOUR GIFT AND OUR GIFT TO
AMERICA.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
>> THE GUY WHO WAS DRIVING ME
THIS MORNING, HE STARTED
WATCHING THE
"OPRAH WINFREY SHOW" AND HE
WOULD SEE HER WALK IN THE AISLE
WITH THE AUDIENCE AND SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT SHE WOULD COVER
AND HE SAID, I KNEW THAT SHE WAS
A GOOD HUMAN.
AND I WANT TO FEEL THE THINGS
THAT ARE IN THIS ROOM AND IT IS
GETTING TO ME.
AT THE BOTTOM LINE, SHE REALLY
IS A GREAT HUMAN WHO JUST WANTS
TO DO GOOD IN THE WORLD.
>> Laura: I LOVE IT!
WHY DO I TALK LIKE THIS?
>> I HOPE WHEN THEY OPEN THE
SMALL ITALIAN AMERICAN MUSEUM
AROUND THE MALL THAT YOU WILL
GIVE AN EMOTIVE REPORT LIKE THAT
ON FOX WHEN YOU STAND THERE.
>> Laura: I LOVE IT WHEN
RAYMOND DID A SEGMENT ABOUT THE
PILE OF POO.
APPEARED TO JUSTIN
THOMAS GETS LIKE A MILLIMETER.
>> THE ARTISTIC FIGURE IN THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN EXPERIENCE, HE
GETS A HORN AND A CASE, NO
EXHIBIT HALL FOR HIM.
WHY CAN'T WE SEE LOUIS
ARMSTRONG'S PERFORMANCES?
SAMMY DAVIS JUNIOR?
A GREAT AFRICAN-AMERICANS, WHERE
ARE THERE FULL-SIZE EXHIBITS?
THIS IS A BIG OVERKILL.
>> Laura: HOSTING A HEADLINE,
THE NEW OPERA EXHIBIT TO LOOKS
LIKE A REWARD FOR HER
$20 MILLION DONATION.
BUT SHE DESERVES IT.
>> SHE IS THE LARGEST SINGLE
DONOR TO THE MUSEUM, THEY HAVE A
THEATER NAMED AFTER HER.
HERE'S WHAT I WANT, THE PHIL
DONAHUE EXHIBIT.
HE WAS THE FIRST TALK SHOW
BEFORE OPRAH.
>> Laura: THE STATUS NEWS WAS
CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER ANNOUNCING
THAT HE ONLY HAS A FEW WEEKS TO
LIVE.
TWEETING OUT A COMMENT SAYING DO
TO CANCER IT IS A HEARTBREAKER.
>> OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE